Right here in our diagram, you can see that the only interesting aspect of what
has changed is that this function object is not storing the methods container
object at the key.methods, instead, it's being stored at the key.prototype.
People tend to get very, very tripped up at this point because they start to
imagine that this .prototype property has some special rules about it
that will influence how this code ought to work.
But in truth, nothing interesting has changed.
The only thing that's different is we've chosen to use a different name
to talk about that storage object where we're putting all of the methods.
And perhaps it's slightly interesting that the language provided that object for
us, but that object does not have any unique or
interesting aspect about it that we've discussed so far.